was it killing you all those years like
you do a bit part on this one or like
you were on Seinfeld and people don't
even know that now they realize it but
you know is it killing you cuz you know
you're a great actor inside and the
public doesn't know you and Hollywood
doesn't really wanted to have that
opportunity well you said the key word
Robin because the only thing that actors
really need and want is opportunity if
they get a chance to walk in the room
then that's up to them but if you never
get that chance it's it's it's hard to
have a career isn't it amazing how many
good actors there are who never get that
chance unbelievable yeah and all the
acting classes that I've been in I've
seen brilliant actors who can who I've
never seen again I see guys on Broadway
you know they do okay but they they
never break through to the next level
movies and all this kind of stuff the
reason is there's a component that
actors fail to understand or completely
Embrace and that is if you have talent
let's say everybody has the same Talent
right you have talent you have
perseverance and you have patience but
there's a component that you absolutely
have to have in order to have a
successful career career as an actor
writer or director and that's luck you
cannot have there has not been a
successful career in our business
without looking back and going oh that
was a lucky break and that was a lucky
break I had two you're right if you
hadn't gotten that small part on X Files
he would have been screwed I wrote a
movie for my wife a little romantic
drama for a birthday present and then
she's read it and goes oh this is
fantastic when are we going to do it and
I thought oh never I thought if I
could just write this you know so then I
started it was put away for years and
then I thought okay I'm just going to go
do this so I raised some money got some
friends and put in money how much money
do you need to raise to make a decent
movie but well back then we we shot on
35mm film now I would do it digitally
right um but we I had 300,000 okay so we
went out and I kept delaying it because
I'd get an actor I'd lose an actor and
we kept delaying it delaying it delay
finally I said we just got to go went
left La for 3 weeks Shot the movie came
back I was in editing for 3 days and my
agent calls me and says we have an
audition for you I don't know if you
want to get I know I I need it I'm broke
right okay it's for X Files I happen to
look the part a big nasty mustache and
you know sideburns down to my loes you
know and I thought okay I could do this
and that was the episode that Vince wow
wrote in that episode of xfiles so what
my father says is true no matter what
role it is big or small you got to give
it your best because you never know
what's going to come out of that thing
you blew away Vince Gilligan when you
did the X Files I actually blew him you
blew I thought so that's what
remembered